hat es zugibt dass er ist so sehr liebt
er kann nicht mehr ohne es ist leben
wir machen machen es anders
ok service packs kids es geht los mit
neuen runden mit sitzplätzen mit messer
wetzen ak max macht auch gerne genannt
in der tat
er wird auch momenten ich habe dieses
video heute für eine ganz besondere
person in meinem leben gemacht zwar für
den blues denn sie uns wissen
aufgeflogen wir haben uns erwischt
ich bin jetzt hier mit dem markt weil
der mich verhören will ich glaube ich
habe mich verhört
ich glaube nicht doch doch doch sie
haben sich verhört herr kommissar bellut
wir haben anschuldigen gegen uns
anschuldigung ganz ganz gravierende
anschuldigung läuft weil ich war schon
richtig gut gebaut herr kommissar
also ich muß damit meinen patienten der
eigentlich genauso hoch eingestellt
früher musste ich erstmal den erfahrung
bringt unter
ist uns bekannt geworden dass die beiden
christel konsumieren
und als folge dessen ist mein partner
hat fast an einen anfall gestorben
blut
es tut mir leid ich kann es nicht
leugnen
mutig recht wenig kaliber endlich kann
ich weiß nicht lachen
ich kann nur das sagen es war eine
fehlinformation auf jeden fall
nutztieren beweismaterial gegen uns wir
haben dessen beweis
wir haben und weiß dass die beiden
crystal meth nehmen
das finde ich gut und zwar ich werde
jetzt zeigen was zu angeregten aber
nicht vor denn nicht vor den leuten
nicht nein mann ich war nicht mal nicht
mal nicht zeigt sich nicht erst im laufe
noch vorbringen müssen zeigt es nicht
den leuten
nein gar nicht dachte die leute wissen
das nicht mitbekommt flugzeug liefern
die kanzlei hat von mir verlangen so
nehmen sie rücksicht auf das
wirtschaftsgeschehen
zunächst will ihr zeigen was aus ihm
geworden ist was ist das was ist aus ihm
geworden
die nbs as roma gerichtet haben
die bringen gleich drei top drogen haben
holla die waldfee oder kommen andere
nein auch com/press kind möchte das aber
leute heute wir haben heute ist mir
nicht nach lachen zumute ich bin einer
der traurigsten tage meines lebens ich
wurde wurde entfernt durch spiele egal
mein spieler sehen es geht so weit
wir können das nur wegen er hat einen
anfall mainka lieb ist
so kann nur warten
ich kann das nur lachen
kommissar gehen dem büro nach und frank
beamtenbeleidigung deutschen
der mit pfeil und bogen zwischen zeitung
ich habe gesagt ich habe das ein problem
der emd auf mich ist nichts was du getan
haben
aber es ist nicht zu unterschätzen
das kann sich an machen
bedenklich war schon alles natürlich
aber ich habe ein ort der alle medien
kurz dem volleyball für mich im gold
saft und habe den zweiten auch zugeben
dass er es sehr lieb lieb ins gericht
er kann nicht mehr ohne s leben und auch
nicht mehr ohne escape zusammen
konservieren sie ist immer weiter
christmas aktuell gehört und wieder muss
ich da was von giotto wasser war ich
dachte du wärst mein bruder sein sollte
das etwa direkt sagen oder wie das
könnte ich nicht was herz bringen weiß
kommst du es neben tun
ok
meinetwegen aber nicht missen ich habe
gerade im guten bogen schon abgegeben
erzählt dass entschuldigung oder wird
das strafmildernd
gibt es eine änderung für eine strafe
kommt nicht jeder tolle plan to the
flowers blogs blog.com ich hab keinen
bogen
ich hab genug für uns beide heute sind
die bilder ja einfach so viele stücke
auf den weg gelegt bleiben ja der punkt
wo ich ein problem der bogen in bogen
ich blocke blockt gut ab aber er mich
auch das war nicht so gut
aber kann das schaffen es zurzeit ja was
sagst du dazu
also kann das jetzt einfach nur lachen
und sofort nichts beleben
kern des neuen schuldig
die hand müsse jetzt aufhören oder sie
will zunächst lassen wird ich werde
niemals werde es niemals lassen können
aber ich werde also mit anderen
umtreiben
ich werde es mit anderen konsumieren zb
mit dem neben es nicht tun sie es ab
jetzt auch wird es ein treffen fragt
kann es nicht lassen
was ich getan habe oben diese kuhle golf
plattform gebaut mit der novelle sollte
gehen kann
kannst du mir verzeihen nein das habe
ich schon die spender da oben oder wurde
jetzt ab und der 3000
aber ok getroffen
der bot sich ein die bauen sich eine so
krass hochaltar bottom of the earth was
man erstmal für ein team gehen ab
welches ich will der soll der betroffene
nicht billiger war okay auch angesagte
grüne liegt im bett mehr stimmt dann
bitte an unser team sammeln acht
deswegen hatte sich so hoch gebaut das
nicht so mein okay jetzt verstehe ich
das motto einer kommst du uns einer
kommt zu uns hatte aber der kern dürfte
jetzt hinterher intelligenter designer
und ich dachte wenn er hinter mir
verdammt
sie hatte hinter dem ausland holen und
kann sich aufhalten kann sie aufhalten
ein verdammt netter kerl aber kill your
stuff oder ich hab nichts oder lauf
zurück
ich bin tot bittere nummer ist jetzt war
es allein aber du kannst mich verhören
in zwischenzeit
ich guck dich noch eigentlich vorn
bringen kann bereits material macht real
für meinen combo auf stufe zu heißen
okay war noch beweisen
ok es gar kein bauer in der base die
gelegenheit nutzen und ich tue einfach
was ich kann ich versuche einfach der
welt jetzt abzubauen
was soll ich sonst machen die schuld
wieder wett zu machen um mich wieder
reinzuwaschen von ihrer von dieser
schuld die zentnerschwer auf meinen
schultern lastet nein wahrscheinlich
kann ich einfach so dumm ab ob gott
komme schnauze so willig er bestimme ich
nicht ohne witz als ob ich das jetzt
nicht erwischt dieses bett ich bitte
euch doch geschafft ist ganz ehrlich
wenn ich das nicht schaffe dann
schließlich mehrfach problem sei wenig
leben ok jetzt darin dass hardware
wichtig wieder etwas neben der spur
läuft das bisschen neben der spur ich
gefühlt aber die schweiz stadtplan
maxi kritik laut ok neuer
rechtschreibung jetzt gibt es road gegen
mich als ob und beide kämen der mitte 12
gold was kann sie mit 12 volt holen
geben sie mir die tipps red yoopress tg
camberg und kommt eine 8 und 8 und eine
ok dann habe ich
ja was kann mache ich treffe ja aber
oder solche mit stärksten holen du
kannst doch beide stehen die kosten 3
was recht und zwar gut beim gold ab
bernd mache ich meine stärke paket
ablehnen stärke drei leute irgendwas
der hohe goldpreis stärke krankheit mal
von ihm gehört kann es nicht
entschuldigen
das einzige was ich jetzt tun kann es so
gut wie möglich wieder runde bett zu
sein
sonst schaffen
bleibt die kollektive setzen als ob sie
lieber meinem eine tränke gestreuten hat
dabei die rettungsplattform aktiviert
das ist stark gm habe ich uns landen
auch oder gfc im bett befestigen
ok heimstärke training so und da gebe es
okay das ist so klappt alle leute ich
hab kein bett mehr richtig komische wege
gebaut hat ist schon tot passt los alter
wird gebaut
natürlich waren wir die com oder hatte
ich kann mich hier hoch
ich hab' ich habe kein bett mehr und ich
hab mal zwei gegner denn wenn dich
zerstören muss und die ich dann auf
kaputt machen muss
das wird richtig knapp aber ich habe
eine starke tag aber ich habe den sprung
gestoppt aber die elf prozent schaffen
abdullah abdullah achtung
das war das treffen glück was für
blogger als fast 8 uhr was die europäer
kann ich hoffe einfach kein bogen alter
ist wird es dass es so knapp wie andere
kurz ich wieder ich denke nicht dass ihn
buchen
es ist so knapp ich werde wahrscheinlich
in produktinnovationen kein problem mit
dem fall schaden haben wirst du ja
welche zerfalle bleiben und jetzt hell
wie justin hat gerade oben weil ich
keine blöcke hatte verdammt geht in der
bronze verdeckungsmord oder lauf den
deko dem projekt im rahmen bieten
laufend satirische ab sondern jetzt
schnell mein gott ich habe das so klappt
es sogar besser gab ich hab's ja ja ja
ja ja ja ja ja
jetzt läuft raus lassen achtung achtung
tier 1 habe ich einen habe ich einen
habe ich ein paar junge ist das knapp
alter ist die scheiße karl-walter er
antritt beide kein bett mehr
eins-gegen-eins andere tut im haus seien
im haus der irgendwo im roten haus der
camp lass mal ich hab mal 20 sekunden
zeit fürs bieten strength das nutze ich
noch mal rein
vergib mir ergebnis
ich rede machte wind ums kann ich mit
ihr kann ich mir jetzt überlegen gerät
machen mit blut und jetzt ja da sehr
schön wunderbar keine runde 5 kg alter
50 des dateien sicher dass matt und warb
dafür dass ich den herzkatheter gegeben
habe noch einmal
aber ich werde dich noch nicht ausreden
aus der familie machten leid weil er im
kopf ich tu dir nur gute besserung
erholung von christoph münchen
ich gehe erst mal in entzugstherapie
leute von 300 bis in sechs monaten